uh people are fleeing uh cities
maybe they're leaving because they're
afraid of the pandemic maybe they're
leaving because their boss gave them the
green light that they could work from
home for some extended period of time
and there was a lot of supply outside of
cities of homes it seems
and inside of cities we have this
massive crunch and a housing crisis
what happens now with this great
flipping that's happened where
people don't want to be in cities and
they don't need to be and cities are
expensive and the country is cheap and
it's better and you just the only reason
you weren't there previously was because
your boss didn't allow it and now your
boss is saying go for it
classic economics right supply and
demand so you have
less expensive uh more plentiful housing
outside of cities although the one thing
i would slightly take issue with
in most areas we didn't really have a
large supply
of existing inventory it was still
relatively
um light by historical standards but it
it certainly wasn't as tight as in some
of the urban areas
but but but i would i would say um you
are seeing
more vacancies and especially at the
high end and some of the
cities where people are moving out and
have the ability to just walk away from
places
and and get places in in less expensive
areas you're seeing
a resurgence in places outside in new
york city like
you know people going back to
connecticut or out to the hamptons and
renting places for a year lots of that
stuff happening
and so i i do have some concerns about
that people the impacts not only on the
housing market in places like new york
but all the small businesses supported
by all the people living there
right that's going to certainly be acute
yeah i mean you don't need as many
restaurants for eye cleaners
even schools and teachers they might be
downsizing as well if people are going
to go
you know and flee to the suburbs